if you love spider-man as much as we do
you probably can't wait for spider-man
into the spider-verse
to come out in theaters in the meantime
let's take a peek behind the curtain and
find out who's voice in our favorite
characters watch until the end to find
out which oscar-winning actor is voicing
spider-man you are now let's take a look
behind the mic of spider-man into the
spider-verse
Stan Lee as Stan the late Stan Lee
managed to get his last cameo in before
passing away in November of 2018 and
believe it or not but this cameo can be
found in spider-man into the spider
verse as many of you know Stan made it a
point to appear in every single Marvel
movie that hit the big screen and as the
executive vice president and publisher
of Marvel Comics we can all agree that
Stan does whatever Stan once this
revolutionary artist lived his life to
the fullest which is why he deserves a
little shout-out or two so how does this
man become a legend well by taking his
career one day at a time without stand
there wouldn't be any spider-man comics
or movies so how did this great man come
up with the idea for spider-man well why
not hear it from Stan's himself Wow
suppose a person had the power to stick
to a wall like an intersect this video
was posted on the CNN YouTube channel
and hosted by Larry King so if you're
going to see the latest spider-man movie
make sure to keep an eye out for the
marvelous Stan Lee zoe kravitz as mary
jane zoe kravitz is the daughter of
renowned singer Lenny Kravitz and famous
actress Lisa Bonet much like her parents
Zoey knew that she wanted to become a
star and so she did Zoey plays the role
of Mary Jane and her calming voice fits
her character perfectly in a clip posted
by the YouTube channel comicbook.com
we can see Mary Jane giving a speech to
a crowd of civilians
they're counting on me probably not you
specifically I think it's a metaphor
Mary Jane's role is trivial to the
spider-man legacy which is why we're
super happy that Zoey snagged the role
acting and voice acting are very
different fields but Zoey had little to
no issues learning the ropes in fact
this isn't her first time in the studio
the actress got some practice when she
landed the role of Catwoman in the Lego
Batman movie on top of that Zoey also
did some voice acting for the TV movie
Morris and the cow Jake Johnson as Peter
B Parker Jake Johnson isn't your
everyday average voice actor and this is
because he spends most of his in front
of the camera opposed to inside a studio
but Jake's quick on his feet and open to
many different challenges he's known for
acting in movies like let's be cops and
the TV series new girl but did you know
Jake is a super successful voice actor
as well while many of us are familiar
with his acting portfolio we know very
little about his other endeavors
Jake landed voice gigs on productions
like Smurfs The Lost village
Bojack horseman and the lego movie all
in all it looks like he was the perfect
fit for his character Peter B Parker you
have money right here's what Jake had to
say about spider-man into the
spider-verse movie while on the Rich
Eisen show but I have you know obviously
I cared about Peter Parker as a kid but
doing press for this I've realized
people care about this universe in ways
I can never imagine so all in all Jake
wasn't ready for the intense spider-man
fanatics that crossed his path during a
comic-con event but then again who would
be Kimiko Glenn as penny Parker Kimiko
Glenn is an adorable actress who is well
known for playing Brooke so so on the
hit TV series orange is the new black
although she might be relatively new to
the acting world Kimiko has managed to
make quite the name for herself in fact
she's even breached into the voice
acting world and with the cute and
feminine voice like hers it was only a
matter of time Kimiko plays the role of
Penny Parker in the latest spider-man
movie
and it's safe to say that she's ready
for business the young actress clicked
with her role overnight and here's what
she has to say about little penny Parker
during an interview with Mulder bill is
that you wouldn't expect this tiny happy
and energetic young girl to be the
heroic pilot of this hulking super bot
much like penny Kimiko is used to being
judged by her appearance so playing a
femme fatale role helped her to break a
stereotype or too much like the other
voice actors in the new spider-verse
movie this isn't Kimiko's first time in
the studio she's known for voicing
characters in TV shows like Bojack
horseman duck tales and Sofia the first
Chris Pine as Peter Parker Chris Pine is
a highly celebrated actor who is known
for playing huge roles in popular movies
like Wonder Woman and Star Trek beyond
he's been acting since 2003 and has
quickly climbed up Hollywood's ladder so
much so that many of us were stoked when
we found out that he'd be voicing the
original spider-man in the new
spider-verse movie well as Chris would
say because his role is basically a
super small cameo in fact his character
is so sporadic that he only gets a
single line in the film so basically
many of us aren't even going to notice
that chris has a role in this highly
anticipated film
but if you're watching this before you
watch the movie you might just be able
to spot him out chris is currently
working on the second installment of the
Wonder Woman franchise so if you like
him as much as we do make sure to catch
his upcoming film Natalie Morales as
Miska eros Natalie Morales was cast as
Miss Kay eros in the upcoming
spider-verse movie and although she
tends to go for very different roles she
couldn't help but break the mold due to
the magnitude of this animated film
according to the actress these are the
roles she tends to go for I tend to stay
away from stereotypical latina or female
things this clip was posted by the
YouTube channel build series where
Natalie explained how she tends to stay
away for stereotypical roles if you're
not familiar with this hilarious
celebrity let us fill you in on her many
accomplishments she's known for playing
Lucy on the hit TV series Parks and
Recreation and Rosie on battle of the
sexes although she has more experience
in front of the camera natalie has been
voice acting for many years now and much
like her cast members she's a recurring
character on the hit TV show Bojack
horseman shamak more as Miles Morales
shamak more is the man of the hour and
he's bringing a new voice to the
spider-man character as the lead actor
in the spider-verse movie shamekh has a
lot of practicing to do but he wanted to
bring a fresh vision to his character
Miles Morales and did he ever I love you
during an interview with flicks in the
city Clips shamekh opened up about what
he wanted to bring to the table the
actor managed to stay true to his vision
which is why millions of spider-man fans
are swooning from his performance shamak
began acting in 2011 and has already
made a name for himself you might
recognize him from TV series like
incredible crew and the get-down
however his most famous role is the one
of Malcolm in dopes believe it or not
but this was show Meeks second time
voice acting throughout his eight-year
career now if that isn't impressive we
don't know what is Hailee Steinfeld as
Gwen Stacy Hailee Steinfeld might be
young but she's had plenty of experience
on and off camera
she's a singer actress and voice actress
and who knows what she'll be up to next
Haley was cast as character Gwen Stacy
and we couldn't be happier about it the
lively celebrity brings charisma and
spunk to Gwen's character and we
wouldn't expect anything less from her
hey guys it's Gwen actually hailey
kick-started her career back in 2007 and
has slowly been learning the ropes ever
since she's known for her roles in
movies like True Grit
the edge of seventeen and pitch perfect
2 while it may be hard to believe this
was Haley's first time voice acting
throughout her career but he would never
be able to tell all in all it seems as
though this girl's unnatural during an
interview that was posted by film artsy
entertainment Haley went on about what
makes spider-verse such an epic movie
here's what she had to say but this film
is so captivating and and funny and
heartwarming and I could go on but go
see it because it really is something
special so there you have it guys
proof that spider-verse is worth the
watch Mahalo Ali as uncle Aaron if
there's one actor we all know and love
it's the famous Maher Sheela Ali this
highly talented actor never fails to
deliver a fantastic performance which is
why we're super excited to see him get
into character in spider-verse Maher
Salah was cast as uncle Aaron who
happens to be Myles paternal uncle while
their relationship might be shaky at
times uncle Aaron is always there to
lend a helping hand to his nephew Aaron
there's some tension between Jefferson
and Aaron rehearsal eyes well known for
his roles in house of cards Luke Cage
and The Curious Case of Benjamin Button
he's an oscar-winning actor who has a
lot left to give
during
interview with flick and the city clips
rehearsal talked about how important
spider-verse
is for our generation and here's what
the talented celeb had to say my child
gets to live in a time where there are
there are more diverse voices all in all
more her Sheila is excited to be part of
a production that unites people instead
of dividing them we don't know about you
but we're super excited to see uncle
Aaron in action Liev Schreiber as Wilson
Fisk Liev Schreiber is no newbie when it
comes to voice acting which is why
producers immediately considered him for
the role of Wilson Fisk as many of you
know Wilson Fisk is a big-time kingpin
who's filled with hate and anger while
he claims to want a better life for a
city he tends to get his hand stuck in
the cookie jar more often than not
leaves character is known for his sudden
bouts of rage which is why staying true
to this role can be a challenge here's a
clip of leave getting into character in
the studio this clip was posted by the
scream slam YouTube channel where we
clearly see leaves face getting red with
rage salable freaking light show you're
gonna love this this famous celeb has
been acting since the early 90s and he
tends to score similar roles due to how
believable his bad guy facade is he's
known for playing Victor Creed in the
x-men origins Wolverine movie were super
excited to see what leave does with his
role Kathryn Hahn as Doc Ock Kathryn
Hahn is probably the most hilarious
actress in Hollywood and we can say that
without any hesitation she's been acting
since the late 90s and managed to become
one of the most sought-after celebs of
our generation her hilarious facial
expressions and voice interpretations
have made her the ideal match for her
spider-verse character Doc Ock although
a man traditionally plays this role
Catherines managed to get producers to
make an exception for her this funny
lady is known for playing in movies like
stepbrothers we're the Millers and bad
moms although catherine has more than
enough experience with voice acting she
was still a bit unfamiliar with the
process the actress also voiced a
character in the movie Hotel
Transylvania 3 summer vacation and this
is what she had to say about being in
the studio while interviewing with
backstage oh well but I was so excited
to be the director who we can't wait to
see what she does with Doc Ock Brian
Tyree Henry asked Jefferson Davis Brian
Tyree Henry is a hilarious and talented
actor known for his work on Atlanta he's
also snagged some roles on hit TV shows
like this is us and Vice Principals all
in all Brian's career is taking off at
full speed and landing the role of
Jefferson Davis in the spider-verse
movie is only going to help him further
in his reach
Brian's character is Miles dad and he
tends to come off as strict and
protective spider-man I mean this guy
swings in
here's what Brian had to say about his
character while interviewing with screen
slam Jefferson Davis is Miles Morales is
dad he's a no-nonsense police officer
who does things by the book and even
though he has a lot of rules for miles
he has a lot of love for his son too
when it comes to being a father it's
obvious that Jefferson takes his role
very seriously keeping his son safe is
his biggest duty so what happens when he
finds out that his son is risking his
life to save everyone else's well you'll
have to watch the movie to find out for
yourself Lily Tomlin as Aunt May Lily
Tomlin is an oscar-winning actress who
knows a thing or two about voice acting
and humor regardless of this she never
expected to be part of a huge cast like
the one found in the spider-verse movie
it's well chosen it's not you might
recognize this big-time actress from the
hit TV series
and Franky we couldn't imagine any other
actress playing the role of Aunt May
other than Lily herself and this has
everything to do with how soothing her
voices lily is used to lending her vocal
cords to a number of productions but
this is the first time she's worked on
something as unique as the spider-verse
film here's what the actress had to say
about the movies animation style while
interviewing with flicks in the city
Clips they showed me the animation it
was just stellar it was so beautiful and
complex you know they mixed cell
animation with computer animation it
goes without saying that without anime
the spider-man movies just wouldn't be
the same
Luna Lauren bez as Rio Morales noodle on
Deus is a highly celebrated actress who
knows a thing or two about bringing the
heat she's playing the role of miles
mother who as many of you know is a
Latina
Luna's character requires her to speak
Spanish but that isn't an issue for the
multilingual actress my family doesn't
run away from things miles you might
recognize Luna from TV shows like Dexter
how to get away with murder and
bluebloods
Luna plays the role of Rio Morales and
her fiery presence helps bring this
character to life during an interview
with screen slam Luna went in-depth
about the importance of diversity and
why she was so happy to be a part of the
spider-verse cast this is what the
actors had to say about her on-screen
son he is some of his diverse families
culture and so there you have it guys
mama Morales in the flesh now let's find
out which oscar-winning actor was dying
to play the role of spider-man noir
Nicolas Cage as spider-man noir Nicolas
Cage is an oscar-winning actor who is
literally obsessed with superheroes as a
matter of fact he uses the last name
cage to honor the Marvel superhero Luke
Cage Nicolas has been trying to get cast
as a superhero for as long as we can
remember he even wrote letters to
producers telling them why he was the
only man for the job unfortunately for
him he has yet to land the role he's
been looking for sometimes I love
matches burned down to my fingertips
just to feel something anything however
he did get cast as spider-man noir in
the newest spider
installment Nikolas couldn't be happier
to be part of a superhero movie and
let's face it he was the perfect choice
for his mysterious black and white
character while interviewing with screen
slam Nikolas went on and on about how
amazing this movie was going to be he
also touched on how spider-verse is the
ideal family flick here's what the
renowned actor had to say so have you
guys seen this movie yet if so let us
know which character is your favorite in
the comments below and that's a wrap
thanks for watching and see you next
time on the things
[Music]